معي الآن الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا ، وهو
كبير المراسلين الطبيين لدينا في CNN.
ما الذي تسمعه سانجاي نعم ، أعني أن
هذه بعض
الأخبار المحزنة من الواضح أنك تعلم أننا كنا
نتابع هذه التجارب لبعض الوقت
أه هذا أحد المتطوعين في
التجربة  تجربة فيروس كورونا
أسترازينيكا في
البرازيل ونسمع أن هذه الوفاة حدثت
يوم الإثنين
، تنبه وكالة الصحة العامة الآن
أشخاصًا آخرين
إلى هذه الوفاة ، لكنها تقول أيضًا في
نفس الوقت بريانا أن المحاكمة
ستستمر ، ليس من الواضح في البداية على الأقل عندما
تسمع  هذه الأنواع من التقارير المتعلقة بالديون
ما حدث بالضبط أو حتى إذا
تلقى الشخص اللقاح أو تلقى
الدواء الوهمي عندما تتعامل مع عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص في هذه التجارب
أه أعتقد أن النقطة التي يثيرونها
هي أنه في بعض الأحيان الوفيات  يمكن أن تحدث
حتى في مجموعات الدواء الوهمي
لأسباب لا علاقة لها بحقيقة أنهم
مستمرون في التجربة قد يكون دليلًا بسيطًا
ولكننا ما زلنا نحصل على مزيد من التفاصيل حول
هذا وستتذكر الآن بريانا ،
هذه هي المرة الثالثة
التي يكون لدينا فيها نوع من
التأثير الضار مثل هذا المبلغ عنه مرة أخرى غير
واضح
أن هذا كان بسبب اللقاح ولكن
مرة أخرى في يوليو ، تم
إيقاف تجربة أسترازينيكا مؤقتًا ثم
مرة أخرى  في بداية سبتمبر
قبل حوالي ستة أسابيع
قد تتذكر أنه كان الشخص الذي ظهرت عليه
هذه الأعراض العصبية في
تلك المرحلة أه
صعوبة في المشي هذا النوع من
الأعراض التي توحي بأنه ربما
كان هناك بعض
التأثير للدواء على
العمود الفقري
تعافى ذلك الشخص لاحقًا ولكن
هذا أه هذا هو الشيء
الذي يبحث عنه هؤلاء المحققون هل
هناك آثار جانبية ضارة هي تلك
الآثار الجانبية المتعلقة باللقاح على
وجه التحديد
أو لا علاقة لها هل هم في تجربة الدواء الوهمي
وتلك هي نوع من  التفاصيل
التي سنستمر في
محاولتها للحصول على بريانا ، نعم ، لماذا لا
يضعون ذلك هناك لأنني بالتأكيد
أعتقد أنه إذا كان هذا شخصًا ما  إذا
كانوا يتناولون دواءً وهميًا
، فقد يكون الأمر أقل قلقًا أو إذا كان
هناك شيء يمكنهم قوله حول
نوع الأعراض أو سبب الوفاة ،
نعم بلا شك أعني أنه في بعض الأحيان
مصدر إحباط
وستتذكر أنه
حتى العودة إلى  سبتمبر مرة أخرى ، مر
بعض الوقت قبل أن نبدأ في الحصول على
تفاصيل حول ما حدث على وجه التحديد لذلك
المريض كان زميلي إليزابيث
كوهين يحصل على بعض تلك التفاصيل ، حيث
تم إيقاف التجربة
في الولايات المتحدة ولكن تم استئنافها بعد ذلك
في المملكة المتحدة ، لذا يبدو الأمر وكأنه  قليل من
الخلط
ما يحدث على ما أعتقد هو أن هناك
كيانًا مستقلًا هو لوحة مراقبة سلامة البيانات
وهم الوحيدين حقًا
الذين من المفترض أن يكونوا قادرين على إلغاء
التعمية للبيانات ، لا يفعل
الباحثون الذين
يقدمون اللقاح بالفعل  لا أعرف ما إذا كانوا يعطون
اللقاح أو العلاج
الوهمي الأشخاص الذين يتلقون هذا
المتطوعين الذين لا يعرفون ،
لذا فالطريقة التي من المفترض أن تعمل بها هي
أن لديك كيانًا واحدًا
مستقل
يمكنه إلغاء التعتيم على البيانات
ومعرفة ما حدث هنا على وجه التحديد
والذي قد يستغرق أحيانًا بعض الوقت
لا ينبغي أن يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً أعتقد أنه يجب
أن ينشروا هذه
البيانات ونأمل أن يفعلوا ذلك
ولكن اعتبارًا من الآن جميعًا  نعلم أنه
كان هناك متطوع
في التجربة مات ، ولا نعرف
الكثير في التفاصيل من حيث
أه أي شيء عن الشخص الذي كان عمره في سنه
، والأهم من ذلك أننا لا
نعرف حتى ما إذا كانوا قد تلقوا  اللقاح أم لا ،
حيث نحصل على تلك التفاصيل التي أعتقد
أننا سنحصل بالتأكيد على
ضوء أوضح قليلاً على ما حدث بالضبط
هنا
أنا سكوت ماكلين في برلين حيث لا تظهر
الموجة الثانية من فيروس كورونا في أوروبا
أي علامات على التباطؤ
أبلغت ألمانيا عن المزيد من
الوفيات الناجمة عن فيروس كورونا خلال الأسبوع الماضي مقارنة بما حدث
في شهر أغسطس بأكمله ،
وكانت البلدان الأكثر تضررًا هي
هولندا ، بلجيكا والآن جمهورية التشيك ،
أمس ، صنع وزير الصحة التشيكي
الأقنعة.
تقريبًا في كل مكان في الهواء الطلق ، وقد
أقر رئيس الوزراء هذا الصباح بعد
جلسة طارئة
للبرلمان أن
القيود الحالية المطبقة
ببساطة لم تنجح ، لذا بدءًا من
الغد ، ستعود جمهورية التشيك
إلى شيء قد
تصفه بأنه إغلاق لن يُسمح إلا للشركات الأساسية
للبقاء مفتوحًا
وستقتصر الحركة
بشدة على
الرحلات الأساسية والعمل
مع نظام الرعاية الصحية في البلاد الذي
يقترب من قدرته
، وستقبل جمهورية التشيك أيضًا
أطباء من
الحرس الوطني الأمريكي في نبراسكا ،
وقد تم الإشادة برئيس الوزراء لنجاحه المبكر
في الدك  أسفل
الموجة الأولى من الفيروس التاجي الآن وهو
يعتذر عن عدم اتخاذ إجراءات
عاجلة لكبح الموجة الثانية